This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Here, let me give you these. Oh, thank you. These are your plugs. Let me take you back, back to a simpler time. The year 2016. What is this? So this is Recycling Plant. This is the large recycling plant. Where we sort all the materials from the blue bin, the bottles, the cans, the paper.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马斯。来，我把这个给你。哦，谢谢。这是你的耳塞。让我带你回到过去，回到一个更简单的时代。2016年。这是什么？所以这是回收厂。这是大型回收厂。我们在那里对蓝色垃圾桶里的所有材料进行分类，包括瓶子、罐子和纸张。
In 2016, producer Avery Trouffman was working on a story about garbage and recycling pickup systems its episode 2.13. But don't worry, this is not a rerun. This story is different. Back then, for that story in 2016, I took a tour of the plant that sorts all of San Francisco's recycling. We do 600 tons a day here. That's Robert Reed, the representative
2016年，制作人艾弗里·特鲁夫曼正在做一个关于垃圾和回收收集系统的报道，这是第 2.13 集。但别担心，这不是重播。这个故事有所不同。当时，为了2016年的那篇报道，我参观了负责对旧金山所有回收物进行分类的工厂。我们这里每天处理600吨。那是罗伯特·里德，他是
for San Francisco Recology, which is the company that is responsible for San Francisco's recycling program. They're trucks round up all the recycling around the city and bring it to a murf. Murf, MRF, a materials recovery facility. At the murf, the trucks dump all the recycling into a big mountain, and then the wild part begins. This particular Murph in San Francisco
旧金山生态回收公司（San Francisco Recology）的代表，该公司负责旧金山的回收计划。他们的卡车在全城收集所有回收物，并将其运送到垃圾分拣中心（MRF）。垃圾分拣中心，即材料回收设施。在分拣中心，卡车将所有回收物倾倒成一座大山，然后疯狂的部分就开始了。旧金山的这个特定分拣中心
has all this elaborate machinery that looks like it's out of a Miyazaki movie. You see a recycling superstructure. It's three stories high. Pretty shortly, the conveyor belts start up. We're going to sort all this material here into 16 different types of material. This three story tall superstructure and the 173 people that were working on it were separating and cleaning the recycling, sorting it into glass, paper, plastic, etc.
拥有所有这些精密的机械，看起来就像出自宫崎骏的电影。你看到了一座回收超级建筑。它有三层楼高。很快，传送带就启动了。我们要把这里的所有材料分类成16种不同的材料。这座三层楼高的超级建筑以及在里面工作的173人正在对回收物进行分离和清洁，将其分类为玻璃、纸张、塑料等。
You can separate through a combination of hand sorting and modern recycling equipment. Modern recycling equipment like the optical sorter that can automatically separate different color plastics. Right here the scanner is looking at the materials as they come by and when it sees a clear plastic like a clear plastic water bottle it hits it with a puff of air and you can hear it. It's expensive, it costs $3 million for this machine and it came from the Netherlands. And at the time, in 2016, when I was younger and things were simpler, I didn't quite grasp the simple fact. They weren't actually recycling anything.
你可以通过人工分拣和现代回收设备的结合来进行分离。现代回收设备，比如可以自动分离不同颜色塑料的光学分拣机。就在这里，扫描仪正在扫描流经的材料，当它看到透明塑料（如透明塑料水瓶）时，会用一股气流击中它，你能听到声音。它很贵，这台机器价值300万美元，来自荷兰。而在当时，在2016年，当我更年轻、事情更简单的时候，我并没有完全理解这个简单的事实。他们实际上并没有回收任何东西。
They were not churning the paper into pulp or melting down the plastic into pellets. The mirth was simply sorting and cleaning all the materials. They were loading bales of clean recycling onto shipping containers, so they could sell them to mills who would then pulp the paper and melt the plastic. And I was just like, okay, cool. And left well enough alone. I just figured all those mills and plants would always be there wherever they were, waiting to accept our stuff.
他们没有把纸张搅成纸浆，也没有把塑料熔化成颗粒。分拣中心只是对所有材料进行分类和清洁。他们将一包包干净的回收物装上集装箱，以便将它们卖给造纸厂，由造纸厂将纸张打成纸浆并熔化塑料。我当时就想，好吧，太酷了。然后就不管了。我只是以为所有这些造纸厂和工厂无论身在何处，都会一直在那里，随时准备接受我们的东西。
How could I have known that in the new future, this global recycling system would go off the rails? It happened right under our noses, and most people, including me, until very recently, had no idea. The industry has been using the phrase the end of recycling as we know it. Kate O'Neill is an associate professor in the Department of Environmental Science, Policy, and Management at UC Berkeley, and she kind of freaked me out. Yeah, you know, I would say for a lot of stuff that we threw into the recycling, it's not happening. A lot of recycling is no longer actually getting recycled.
我怎么会知道，在不久的未来，这个全球回收系统会彻底失控呢？它就在我们眼皮底下发生了，大多数人，包括我，直到不久前都一无所知。业内一直在使用“我们所知的回收利用的终结”这一短语。凯特·奥尼尔是加州大学伯克利分校环境科学、政策与管理系的副教授，她把我吓得够呛。是的，你知道，我想说的是，对于我们扔进回收站的大部分东西，这种情况并没有发生。许多回收物实际上不再被真正回收了。
The list of accepted materials are shrinking in some cities. Depending on where you live, certain types of plastic aren't being collected anymore, maybe certain kinds of paper or cardboard. In many communities, local governments to stop picking up recycling? Oh, just, just stopped. Yeah, goes in the general trash. Even if they do collect it,
在某些城市，接受的材料清单正在缩短。根据你居住的地方，某些类型的塑料可能不再被收集，也许还有某些种类的纸张或纸板。在许多社区，地方政府停止收集回收物了吗？哦，就是，直接停止了。是的，直接进了普通垃圾桶。即使他们收集了，
they've had a hard time finding places to ship it. Instead of making money, selling recycling, recycling companies are losing money on it. Now they are paying someone to take it. To just store it. Yes. Because they lost their biggest buyer, the place America, and much of Australia and Europe and Canada,
他们也很难找到可以运送的地方。回收公司不仅没有通过出售回收物赚钱，反而在上面赔钱。现在他们得付钱让人把它们拉走。仅仅为了存放它们？是的。因为他们失去了最大的买家——那个美国、澳大利亚的大部分地区、欧洲和加拿大
sent a huge amount of our recycling. This magical land where your empty plastic bottles and old soup cans went to be reincarnated was China. They were taking most of the world scrap. China had been taking most of the world's scrap since about 2001, which is around the time China joined the World Trade Organization. That's when they really ramped up selling goods all over the world in
运送大量回收物的地方。这个神奇的国度，你空空的塑料瓶和旧汤罐都在那里获得新生，那就是中国。他们接收了世界上大部分的废品。自2001年左右以来，中国就一直在接收世界大部分的废品，这大约是中国加入世界贸易组织的时间。也就是从那时起，他们真正开始在世界各地大量销售商品
massive shipping containers. And rather than send the containers back empty, we sent them back filled with recycling, which was actually really cost effective. That's cheap, but to ship scrap from California to China, then California to even Arizona potentially. And this system seemed to work well. Cities could subsidize their recycling pickup programs from the money they made, selling these materials to China. And then they didn't need to process the materials themselves.
巨型集装箱。我们没有让集装箱空着返回，而是将它们装满回收物送回，这实际上非常划算。这很便宜，但将废品从加利福尼亚运到中国，然后从加利福尼亚运到甚至可能还有亚利桑那州。这个系统似乎运作良好。城市可以通过向中国出售这些材料所赚取的钱来补贴他们的回收收集计划。然后他们就不需要自己处理这些材料了。
Capitalism at work. We basically outsourced we gave up on even trying to improve infrastructure here because we could chip it to China. And it seemed like a logical system, as long as China kept wanting to buy our recycling. But then, China pulled a move that no one saw coming. Operation National Sword. A pretty aggressive name for a piece of recycling legislation. Basically, National Sword is China's ban on the import of foreign recyclables. It started in 2018, and the list of banned items has steadily grown. It has the potential of banning all recyclable materials by 2020. But we don't know if that will happen or not.
资本主义在发挥作用。我们基本上进行了外包，我们甚至放弃了在这里改善基础设施的努力，因为我们可以把它运到中国。只要中国一直想买我们的回收物，这似乎就是一个符合逻辑的系统。但随后，中国采取了一个谁也没有预料到的举动。国家剑行动。一个针对回收立法的相当激进的名字。基本上，国剑行动就是中国对进口洋垃圾的禁令。它始于2018年，被禁物品清单在稳步增长。到2020年，它有可能禁止所有可回收材料。但我们不知道这是否会发生。
It's hard to pinpoint exactly why China got fed up with this system all of a sudden. There are a number of factors you can point to, but a lot of experts think it's because of a movie. This Chinese documentary called Plastic China by director Wang Ji-long. It focuses on this insanely cute little girl whose family works at a plastic recycling facility. She never gets sent to school because she's helping her parents watch her younger siblings and sort through mountains of shredded plastic. They're cutting up plastic, melting it, soaking it, and turning it into a sludge, and then
很难确切指出为什么中国突然对这个系统感到厌倦。你可以指出很多因素，但许多专家认为这是因为一部电影。这部由导演王久良拍摄的中国纪录片名叫《塑料中国》。它聚焦于一个极其可爱的小女孩，她的家人在一个塑料回收厂工作。她从来没有去过学校，因为她要帮父母照顾年幼的弟弟妹妹，并在成山的碎塑料中进行分拣。他们在切割塑料、将其熔化、浸泡，变成污泥，然后
turning that into hardened pellets. The little girl washes her face in the gray plastic-y water and eats fish that have choked on plastic. This family lives with the shredding machine. They eat and sleep near it. Enhaling the dust, the micro particles that come off during the shredding process, and the fumes from the melting process. There's a lot of bad stuff there. And all the plastic. It's all clearly from Western countries.
将其变成硬化颗粒。小女孩在灰色的塑料污水中洗脸，吃着因吞食塑料而窒息的鱼。这家人与碎纸机生活在一起。他们就在它附近吃饭和睡觉。吸入粉碎过程中产生的灰尘、微颗粒，以及熔化过程中的烟雾。那里有很多有害物质。还有所有的塑料。很显然全部来自西方国家。
The little girl longingly cuts out shoes from a discarded European catalog, and gleefully plays with dirty old figurines of Mickey Mouse. It is absolutely heartbreaking. And it broke a lot of hearts on the International Film Festival Circuit. And then it was also shown in China for a while, I think it got on the internet there, but the government certain yanked it from Chinese internet. And while I we can't keep doing this. This movie did really make a difference. Yes, yes, I believe it did.
小女孩渴望地从废弃的欧洲产品目录中剪下鞋子，高兴地玩着米老鼠的脏旧小雕像。这绝对是让人心碎的。它让国际电影节巡展上的许多人心碎。后来它也在中国上映了一段时间，我想它曾出现在那里的互联网上，但政府肯定把它从中国互联网上撤下了。虽然我们不能再这样下去了。这部电影确实起到了作用。是的，是的，我相信它确实做到了。
Causing or correlation, it was after this documentary that China instituted Operation National Sword. China realized that they needed to crack down on these informal recycling plants and build safe, efficient recycling systems. They want to improve their own domestic recycling rates and their cities and towns. They have a lot of work to do.
是因果关系还是巧合，正是在这部纪录片之后，中国实施了“国剑行动”。中国意识到，他们需要严厉打击这些非法的非正规回收厂，并建立安全、高效的回收系统。他们希望提高本国城市和城镇的国内回收率。他们有很多工作要做。
And they have more than enough stuff to recycle without taking on more from other countries. So they decided to stop accepting our recyclables. Which I mean, fair enough. It's a good move for them. I think China was no longer interested in being what never really wanted to be, but felt like it was being seen as the garbage dump of the world. You know, it's not its responsibility to take in all of our trash. It's got a point. And so now here we are, Blinking, into the cold harsh light of 2019.
而且，无需承担来自其他国家的更多垃圾，他们就已经有足够多的东西要回收了。所以他们决定不再接收我们的可回收物。我的意思是，这很公平。这对他们来说是个好举动。我认为中国不再有兴趣成为那个从未真正想成为、但感觉被视为世界垃圾场的东西。你知道，接收我们所有的垃圾不是它的责任。这话说得对。所以现在我们在这里，
National sword has been in action for about a year now. Some people call it a crisis or there's no like the word crisis, but that's where we are. Although I feel like it got a little buried in the news cycle, that is, unless you are a dedicated reader of Wasteive. Wasteive is a trade publication. We cover the waste recycling industry, just generally the future of what happens to the materials we buy and throw away.
眨着眼睛，面对2019年冷酷严峻的现实。“国剑行动”已经实施了一年左右。有些人称之为危机，或者人们不喜欢“危机”这个词，但这就是我们的现状。虽然我觉得它在新闻循环中有点被淹没了，除非你是《WasteDive》的忠实读者。WasteDive是一个行业刊物。我们报道废物回收行业，广义上讲就是我们购买和扔掉的材料的未来走向。
Cole Rosengren is the senior editor. And reading Wasteive, it's like reading the news from the upside down. It's a parallel world where the things we do in the realm of the shiny and new are perfectly reflected in the grimy and used. Because Waste Systems are affected by so many factors, local resources, global policy,
科尔·罗森格伦（Cole Rosengren）是高级编辑。读《WasteDive》就像在读来自颠倒世界的新闻。这是一个平行世界，我们在光鲜亮丽的新事物领域所做的事情，在肮脏陈旧的事物中得到了完美的反映。因为废物系统受到太多因素的影响：地方资源、全球政策、
packaging and product trends, new material technology, on and on. It's a whole complex system, especially in the US. Ah, super complicated, so more complicated than it ought to be. In the United States, recycling programs vary depending on individual cities, counties, and states. We don't have a national recycling policy. Other countries do in a variety of ways. Here in the US, we do not.
包装和产品趋势、新材料技术，等等。这是一个极其复杂的系统，在美国尤其如此。啊，超级复杂，比它本来应该的要复杂得多。在美国，回收计划因各个城市、县和州而异。我们没有国家层面的回收政策。其他国家以各种方式拥有。而在美国，我们没有。
So in the wake of national sword, it's been up to each individual recycling program to find new buyers wherever they can. Some have started selling their recyclables to Southeast Asia, countries like Vietnam and Malaysia and Thailand. Others are finding domestic markets, at least for certain materials. Others are finding domestic markets, at least for certain materials.
所以在“国剑行动”之后，寻找新买家的重任就落在了每个单独的回收计划身上，他们只能四处寻找。一些人开始将可回收物出售给东南亚，比如越南、马来西亚和泰国的国家。其他人则在寻找国内市场，至少对于某些材料是这样。其他人则在寻找国内市场，至少对于某些材料是这样。
With aluminum and with plastic and paper mills, there are places in the US to send this that will bind this material to make new products with it. And so with that in mind, areas of the country that have an end market in reasonable distance, they're doing okay. And now there's a big push to invest more in domestic recycling infrastructure, which
随着铝、塑料和造纸厂的发展，美国有些地方可以发送这些材料，它们会结合这些材料来制造新产品。因此，考虑到这一点，国内有合理距离的最终市场的地区，他们目前情况还好。现在，人们大力呼吁加大对国内回收基础设施的投资，这
is good. There's over a dozen announcements of either new or expanded paper mills happening in the US. But here's the thing. All these new plastic glass and paper mills will not save us, because now they are getting so inundated with recyclables that they're increasingly putting their own restrictions on what kinds of materials they're willing to accept.
是件好事。美国有十几项关于新建或扩建造纸厂的公告。但问题是。所有这些新的塑料、玻璃和造纸厂并不能拯救我们，因为现在它们被可回收物淹没了，以至于它们越来越多地对愿意接受的材料种类施加自己的限制。
And there's a good reason why all these places started turning away our recycling. The stuff we've been sending them is too dirty. So much of what we throw into the recycling bin is filthy, contaminated with liquids or food waste or oil. And this kind of contamination just ruins the material. So if you're the anal one in your house who is rinsing the yogurt out of the yogurt containers before you throw them out, you are right. You are doing it right. But most people haven't been doing
这些地方开始拒绝我们的回收物是有充分理由的。我们送去的东西太脏了。我们扔进回收桶的很多东西都是肮脏的，被液体、食物残渣或油污污染了。这种污染会毁掉材料。所以，如果你家里那个一丝不苟的人在把酸奶容器扔掉之前会把里面的酸奶冲洗干净，你是对的。你做得很对。但大多数人并没有
it right. The contamination rates have been pretty high and they've risen in the past 10 years or so. As a result, a lot of the stuff we were throwing into the recycling bin was never truly recyclable material in the first place. It was just trash. And a lot of time, it just ended up in landfill or in-saneration. Operation National Sword didn't create these problems. It just revealed them, and then threw them back at us. Well, mostly threw them at the Murphs. They're the ones with the heaps and heaps of useless recycling piling up, and wondering where to put it. It's been a minute since we spoke last,
做对。污染率一直很高，并且在过去十年左右有所上升。结果，我们扔进回收桶的很多东西一开始就根本不是真正可回收的材料。它们只是垃圾。而且很多时候，它们最终只是进了垃圾填埋场或焚化炉。“国剑行动”并没有创造这些问题。它只是暴露了这些问题，然后把它们抛回给我们。好吧，主要是抛给分拣中心。他们才是那些堆积如山的无用回收物不知该往哪里放的人。我们上次通话已经有一段时间了，
and things have happened. So I checked back in with Robert Reed, the representative of San Francisco Recology, who showed me around their plant back in the good old days of 2016. Let's be going on since I saw you last. A lot of things, if you lose your biggest customer, it really upsets the Apple cart. Reed explained that now, in this new buyer's market, mills are only accepting the most easily recyclable items, which means the items that are almost perfectly pure and clean. There's efforts underway to reduce liquids and any food scraps in recycling bins.
发生了很多事情。所以我再次联系了旧金山生态回收公司的代表罗伯特·里德，他在2016年美好的旧时光里带我参观了他们的工厂。自我上次见你以来发生了什么？很多事情，如果你失去了最大的客户，那可真是把事情搞得一团糟。里德解释说，现在，在这个新的买方市场中，造纸厂只接受最容易回收的物品，这意味着几乎完全纯净和干净的物品。人们正在努力减少回收桶中的液体和任何食物残渣。
And so, ecology has been investing more and more in sorting and cleaning technology to make sure they can keep selling, which means they bought more optical sorters. As we speak, we're installing state-of-the-art optical sorters in our plant that came from France. They now have seven high-speed computer-controlled optical sorters. These big elaborate machines that do the work that we don't want to do. But also, the nerfs want us, the consumers, to send them cleaner recycling, which would make recycling less expensive and more efficient for everyone.
因此，生态回收公司一直在加大对分拣和清洁技术的投资，以确保他们能够继续销售，这意味着他们购买了更多光学分拣机。在我们谈话的同时，我们正在厂里安装从法国进口的先进光学分拣机。他们现在拥有七台由电脑控制的高速光学分拣机。这些复杂的大型机器正在做我们不想做的工作。但同时，分拣中心希望我们——消费者——向他们发送更清洁的回收物，这将使每个人的回收成本更低、效率更高。
We're doing things to encourage the public to help us make cleaner bales of recycling. And so we've launched a new initiative in October called Better at the Bin. The key to success is all of us doing a better job at sorting our recyclables. We call this initiative better at the bin. Recology is posting these high production value videos on their social media and on better at thebin.com. To try to convince everyone to take these little steps to be better recyclers. If one half-null bottle or can gets tossed in the recycling bin, the liquids can ruin the
我们正在采取行动鼓励公众帮助我们制造更干净的回收物打包。因此，我们在10月份发起了一项名为“在垃圾桶里做得更好”（Better at the Bin）的新倡议。成功的关键在于我们所有人都要更好地对可回收物进行分类。我们称这项倡议为“在垃圾桶里做得更好”。生态回收公司正在他们的社交媒体上以及 betteratthebin.com 上发布这些制作精良的视频。试图说服每个人采取这些小步骤，成为更好的回收者。如果有半满的瓶子或罐子被扔进回收桶，里面的液体就会毁掉
whole lot. Remember, reduce, reuse, recycle? Well, somewhere along the way, we totally lost track of reduce and reuse and focused too much on recycle. Refuse single use plastics, plastic straws, plastic bags, and plastic coffee couplies. Don't buy plastic water bottles, carry a metal water bottle. Replace plastic bottles. Yes, this is 100% true.
整批东西。还记得“减量、再利用、回收”吗？好吧，在某个过程中，我们完全忘记了减量和再利用，而把过多的精力放在了回收上。拒绝一次性塑料、塑料吸管、塑料袋和塑料咖啡杯。不要买塑料水瓶，随身携带金属水瓶。替代塑料瓶。是的，这百分之百是真的。
We definitely have got to get better about generating less waste and cleaning what we do recycle. But this alone is simplifying the real complexity of the problem. For example, at the end of the interview, Robert Reed pulled out a totally normal looking tube of toothpaste. You can't recycle this container. You still have the metal on the inside, the soft plastic on the outside, the hard plastic neck and cap, and your residual toothpaste on the inside, not to mention the printing.
我们绝对必须在减少垃圾产生和清洁我们回收的东西方面做得更好。但这本身只是简化了问题的真正复杂性。例如，在采访结束时，罗伯特·里德掏出了一管看起来很普通的牙膏。你无法回收这个容器。你里面仍然有金属，外面有软塑料，硬塑料的瓶颈和盖子，以及里面残留的牙膏，更不用说上面的印刷了。
There's four or five materials here, and they all go to landfills or incinerators. And then he pulled out the small aluminum case. And I'm opening it up and inside there's a cake of toothpaste. It's a dry cake and it lasts for 45 days. And at the end of those 45 days, you just drop another cake into the aluminum jar. I mean, can you buy them in the States? I haven't been able to find them in the States yet. This one was purchased
这里有四五种材料，它们最终都会进入垃圾填埋场或焚化炉。然后他掏出一个小铝盒。我把它打开，里面有一块牙膏。这是一块干燥的牙膏，可以使用45天。在那45天结束时，你只需把另一块放进铝罐里。我的意思是，你能在美国买到它们吗？我还没能在美国找到它们。这个是
in France. This struck me as fairly ridiculous. How are we supposed to buy cakes of toothpaste from France that we don't know exist? And it's not like shipping toothpaste across the Atlantic is exactly environmentally friendly. Again, absolutely true. We need to get better at using less and cleaning our cycling and researching what our local systems will accept. Definitely. But like, we throw out a lot of junk because we are sold a lot of junk. So much of this problem is about the products we are sold and have access to. I just getting fed up with the way that we talk about our pollution problem.
在法国买的。这让我觉得相当荒谬。我们怎么能从法国买我们甚至不知道它存在的牙膏块呢？而且把牙膏跨大西洋运送也算不上十分环保。再次强调，绝对正确。我们需要在少用、清洁回收物以及研究当地系统接受什么方面做得更好。当然。但是，我们扔掉了很多垃圾，因为我们被兜售了很多垃圾。这个很大一部分问题与我们被兜售和能够接触到的产品有关。我对我们谈论污染问题的方式感到厌倦了。
Matt Wilkins is a biologist, and he wrote a piece for Scientific American about our current recycling mess. We should not have to fight as individuals against this constant onslaught of plastic. Take, for example, the term litter bug. You don't want to be a litter bug, right? You know, litter bugs are the problem. It's not the fact that we have this unfettered production of billions of containers
马特·威尔金斯是一位生物学家，他为《科学美国人》写了一篇关于我们当前回收困境的文章。作为个人，我们不应该去对抗这种源源不断的塑料冲击。以“乱扔垃圾者”（litterbug）这个词为例。你不想当一个乱扔垃圾的人，对吧？你知道，乱扔垃圾的人才是问题所在。而不是我们拥有这种不受限制的数十亿个容器的生产
happening at all times and no infrastructure to reclaim those materials. In that nickname, litter bug, it was popularized in large part by a group called Keep America Beautiful. This lobbying group, Keep America Beautiful, founded by Pepsi and Coke and Philip Morris, among others. Keep America beautiful was formed in 1953. Around the same time Vermont was creating legislation way ahead of its time, it would have made it illegal
随时随地都在发生，却没有回收这些材料的基础设施。绰号“乱扔垃圾者”在很大程度上是由一个名为“保持美国美丽”（Keep America Beautiful）的组织推广开来的。这个游说集团“保持美国美丽”由百事可乐、可口可乐和菲利普莫里斯等人创立。保持美国美丽成立于1953年。大约在同一时间，佛蒙特州正在制定一项远远领先于时代的立法，该立法将宣称
to bottle anything in a non-refillable container. And of course, the beverage industry was against it. They wanted to frame the problem of waste as something that should be dealt with not by companies, but by consumers. You know, litter box. Keep America Beautiful was essentially a lobbying group. But its masterstroke in consumer shaming came in 1971
用不可重复使用的容器装瓶任何东西都是非法的。当然，饮料行业是反对的。他们希望将废弃物问题定性为一个不应由公司解决、而应由消费者解决的问题。你知道，乱扔垃圾的人。保持美国美丽本质上是一个游说集团。但它在羞辱消费者方面的大招出现在1971年
when they rolled out a very persuasive advertising campaign. Yeah, the crying Indian ad was basically there's a Native American canoeing through like a pristine forest which is apparently right next to a highway. And he paddles right up to the bank of the highway and climbs out and then people are speeding by and then a motorist like basically hit some with a bag of trash and then the camera pans up and there's a tear rolling down his cheek. This ad which featured an Italian actor playing a Native American became iconic but its basic lesson wasn't exactly wrong. People start pollution, People can stop it.
当时他们推出了一个非常具有说服力的广告活动。是的，那个哭泣的印第安人广告基本上是这样的：一个美洲原住民划着独木舟穿过一片原始森林，这片森林显然就紧挨着一条高速公路。他一直划到高速公路的岸边并爬了上去，然后人们飞驰而过，接着一个驾车者基本上用一袋垃圾砸了他，然后镜头摇上，一滴眼泪顺着他的脸颊流了下来。这个由意大利演员扮演美洲原住民的广告成为了标志性的广告，但它的基本教训并没有错。人们制造了污染，人们可以阻止它。
But the ad made it seem that so long as consumers stop littering, all of our garbage woes would be solved, which of course is not true. It let the corporations that were making all those disposable items off the hook. Although to be fair, this is not exactly their stance anymore. Only a few years after the crying Indian ad, keep America beautiful, change their tune. So they actively fought this legislation in a public way, I think up until the early 80s, and then they kind of switched tactics, and have basically since then just been kind of getting in on the Earth Day push and, you know, telling people to recycle and organizing cleanups and stuff.
但这个广告让人觉得，只要消费者停止乱扔垃圾，我们所有的垃圾问题都能得到解决，这当然是不对的。它让那些制造所有这些一次性用品的大公司逃脱了责任。尽管公平地说，这已经不是他们的确切立场了。就在哭泣的印第安人广告播出几年后，“保持美国美丽”改变了他们的基调。因此，他们以公开的方式积极反对这项立法，我认为一直持续到80年代初，然后他们有点改变了策略，从那以后基本上就只是参与地球日的宣传，你知道，告诉人们去回收垃圾并组织清理活动之类的事情。
Representatives from Keep America Beautiful told me that they now advocate recycling legislation and that their corporate partners want to do their part. These days, especially in the shadow of national sword, corporations and governments have had to acknowledge the scale of our recycling problem in a very public way. We're gathered here today to advance solutions to today's recycling challenges. That's the voice of Andrew Wheeler, former coal industry lobbyist and current acting administrator of the Environmental Protection Agency. In November of 2018, the EPA convened a two-hour long panel discussion in an attempt to
“保持美国美丽”的代表告诉我，他们现在倡导回收立法，并且他们的企业伙伴希望尽自己的一份力。如今，特别是在“国剑行动”的阴影下，企业和政府不得不以非常公开的方式承认我们回收问题的规模。我们今天齐聚一堂，是为了推进解决当今回收挑战的方案。这是安德鲁·惠勒的声音，他是前煤炭行业说客，现任环境保护局代理署长。2018年11月，环保局召开了为期两小时的小组讨论会，试图
attempt to deal with the fallout from National Sword. We cannot tackle these challenges alone, which is why we are thrilled to have representatives from nearly every aspect of the material's economy gathered here today. At this literal roundtable, we're all the biggest names in the recycling world, from waste management to Walmart. It's not every day that you get curic and Starbucks and Coca-Cola Pepsi and Dr. Pepper all in the same room together. And I'm really glad you're all here.
试图应对“国剑行动”带来的余波。我们无法独自应对这些挑战，这就是为什么我们很高兴材料经济学各个方面的代表今天齐聚一堂。在这个名副其实的圆桌会议上，汇集了回收世界中所有最大的名字，从废物管理到沃尔玛。你不会每天都看到绿山咖啡、星巴克、可口可乐、百事可乐和胡椒博士同时出现在同一个房间里。我真的很高兴你们都在这里。
Keep America beautiful was there, and Cole Rosengren was also there in the room, covering it for Wasteive. Maybe the CPA summit went way to something? I hate to be so flippin' about that. I mean, maybe it does. That'd be cool. Basically, each representative had like less than one minute to speak, and everyone mentioned a million different problems with our recycling system. But there was this butterfly at the bottom of Pandora's box. This common refrain that companies, recyclers, and municipalities
“保持美国美丽”也在那里，科尔·罗森格伦也在房间里，为《WasteDive》进行报道。也许环保局峰会能带来什么成果？我讨厌对此如此轻率。我的意思是，也许真的能。那挺酷的。基本上，每个代表只有不到一分钟的发言时间，每个人都提到了我们回收系统的数百万个不同问题。但潘多拉魔盒底部有这样一只蝴蝶。公司、回收商和市政当局都提到的
alike all mentioned. Consumers looked for us to give them sustainable products. We need to think about what is the future of packaging. And we have to design the right way. Yes, dear listener, one of the most important solutions to our recycling woes might actually lay in design. At the EPA meeting, the representative from Proctor and Gamble talked about their award-winning container made out of plastic cleaned up from the beach.
共同副歌。消费者寻找我们提供可持续产品。我们需要思考包装的未来是什么。我们必须以正确的方式进行设计。是的，亲爱的听众，我们回收困境的最重要解决方案之一可能实际上在于设计。在环保局会议上，宝洁公司的代表谈到了他们用从海滩上清理出来的塑料制成的主流获奖容器。
What we do with the head and shoulders bottle was we took the iconic white bottle. We use plastic collected from beaches and it became gray, but we sold it that way in consumers' model. Okay, so this was a limited edition product, and I could you not, it was only available in France. Damn it, France! But, the point is, that kind of packaging is possible. These companies have the capacity and the technology. And we can ask for it. I think another thing that we can do is demand better design of everything with the end of life planned from the beginning.
我们对海飞丝瓶子所做的是，我们采用了标志性的白色瓶子。我们使用从海滩收集的塑料，它变成了灰色，但我们在消费者的模具中就是这样销售的。好吧，所以这是一个限量版产品，我没骗你，它只在法国有售。该死的法国！但是，重点是，这种包装是可能的。这些公司有能力和技术。我们可以要求它。我认为我们可以做的另一件事是，从一开始就规划好使用寿命，要求对所有东西进行更好的设计。
Matt Wilkins, the biologist again, and better design can mean a couple of things. Yes, it can mean finding new ways to use recycled materials like that gray head and shoulders bottle, or at the very least it can be making products really easy and efficient to recycle. Everything should be able to break down into its composite materials and separate them in a way that doesn't introduce impurities so they can be used again. And designers can and should visit merfs and mills. They should know how their products and packaging sort or don't sort, whether they break down or don't break down. Designers can also use biodegradable materials or materials like aluminum that recycle more easily than plastic. But the ideal thing is to design products, or even parts of products that don't need to be thrown away at all.
再次是生物学家马特·威尔金斯，更好的设计可以意味着几件事。是的，这可能意味着寻找使用回收材料的新方法，就像那个灰色的海飞丝瓶子一样，或者至少它可以让产品变得非常容易和高效地回收。一切都应该能够分解成其复合材料，并以不会引入杂质的方式将其分离，以便它们可以再次使用。设计师可以也应该参观分拣中心和造纸厂。他们应该了解他们的产品和包装如何分类或不分类，它们是否会分解。设计师还可以使用可生物降解的材料或像铝这样比塑料更容易回收的材料。但最理想的做法是设计根本不需要扔掉的产品，甚至是不需要扔掉的产品部件。
It's down to product design, and that you design things that can be repaired. Like those toothbrushes with the touchable hands. Exactly. Yeah. And cell phones that you can swap components in and out of the Berkeley professor Cato Neal says yes, companies have to design greener products But then the next step is that these shouldn't just be specialty items that should be the norm I guess people have the label on it so people who are environmentally conscious will buy it
这归结于产品设计，即你设计可以修复的东西。就像那些刷毛可更换的牙刷一样。完全正确。是的。还有你可以更换组件的手机。伯克利教授凯托·奥尼尔说，是的，公司必须设计更环保的产品，但接下来的一步是，这些不应该只是特色商品，而应该成为常态。我想人们会在上面贴上标签，这样有环保意识的人就会买它
But it turns out it might mean that people who don't care won't buy it. Well, it seems like there's kind of paradox where we're saying like, you know, don't blame the consumer. There's a whole world of influences, but also like it's up to us to harness the power of capitalism and bend the market to our will as people who spend money. Yeah, which also seems like it's putting the honest kind of back on the consumer now. Well, sometimes I also think it's not just consumers, but how we act as citizens. So listen, in the course of researching this story, I've had various freakouts. At one point, I was defiantly tossing my aluminum cans in the trash, like, wake up, people, recycling isn't real!
但事实证明，这可能意味着不关心的人不会买它。好吧，这似乎有点悖论，我们一方面说，你知道，不要责怪消费者。有各种各样的影响因素，但另一方面，作为花钱的人，我们要掌握资本主义的力量，按照我们的意志扭曲市场。是的，这似乎又把责任回溯到了消费者身上。嗯，有时我也认为，这不仅关乎消费者，还关乎我们作为公民的行为。所以听着，在研究这个故事的过程中，我经历过各种各样的崩溃。有一段时间，我挑衅性地把铝罐扔进垃圾箱，心想，醒醒吧，人们，回收根本不是真的！
But that's not quite true. Like, don't do what I did. Instead, ask around and find out what is happening to the recycling where you live. This is a system that has been kept deliberately invisible for the sake of our convenience. And we need to learn how to notice it and really think about how our stuff is
但那并不完全正确。就像，别学我这样做。相反，四处打听，了解你居住的地方回收物到底发生了什么。为了我们的方便，这个系统一直被刻意保持隐形。我们需要学会注意到它，并认真思考我们的东西是如何
made and where it's going when we throw it away. Operation National Sword could be a wake-up call, but only if everyone can hear it. Okay, you might be skeptical that design can really make a difference in recycling, but I assured you it can, not just product design, but systems design. Take for example Taipei, the capital of Taiwan. They became one of the cleanest cities in the world in only a few years by using singing garbage trucks. That full story. After this. At the top of the show, I referenced an episode that Avery reported back in 2016, we called it
制造的以及当我们扔掉它时它去了哪里。“国剑行动”可以成为一记警钟，但前提是每个人都能听到它。好吧，你可能会怀疑设计是否真的能在回收中发挥作用，但我向你保证它会的，不仅是产品设计，还有系统设计。以台湾首府台北为例。通过使用会唱歌的垃圾车，他们在短短几年内就成为了世界上最干净的城市之一。完整的故事。稍后继续。在节目开始时，我提到了艾弗里在2016年做的一期报道，我们称之为
separation anxiety. People really loved it, so if you missed it back then, here it is now. Enjoy. If you can recognize any piece of classical music, I bet it's this one. This is Fure Elise, written by Ludwig Van Beethoven in 1810. Maybe it reminds you of piano lessons you took when you were a kid. In my town, it was also the song the ice cream truck used to play. That's producer Avery Trouffleman.
分离焦虑。人们真的很喜欢它，所以如果你当时错过了，现在就来看看吧。享受吧。如果你能认出任何一首古典音乐，我敢打赌就是这首。这是路德维希·范·贝多芬于1810年创作的《致爱丽丝》。也许它让你想起小时候上的钢琴课。在我的小镇上，这也是冰淇淋车经常播放的歌曲。那是制作人艾弗里·特鲁夫曼。
But if you live in Taiwan, and you hear a truck rumbling down the street playing Fear Elise, it doesn't mean it's time to buy a popsicle. It means it's time to take out your trash, because this is what a garbage truck in Taiwan sounds like. This garbage truck song isn't just supposed to be cute and fun, although it is also supposed to be cute and fun. The singing garbage trucks are all a part of a completely different way of thinking about waste disposal. Completely different that is from the way that we think about it in the United States.
但如果你住在台湾，听到一辆卡车在街上隆隆驶过，播放着《致爱丽丝》，那并不意味着是时候买冰棒了。这意味着是时候拿你的垃圾出门了，因为这就是台湾垃圾车的声音。这首垃圾车之歌不只是为了显得可爱有趣，尽管它确实也旨在显得可爱有趣。会唱歌的垃圾车完全是关于一种截然不同的垃圾处理思考方式的一部分。这与我们在美国的思考方式完全不同。
In the late 1990s Taiwan recycled only 5% of its waste. Today Taiwan recycles well over half. The country is now among the world's top recyclers. In what changed in this period has a lot to do with the way that the trash is collected. Okay, Fureliis isn't the only song the trucks play. In Taipei, the capital of Taiwan, the trucks also play this song. That's Amadens Prayer, my Polish composer, Tecla Barozuzka Barozka. And in Taipei City, the garbage trucks just alternate between these two songs.
在20世纪90年代末，台湾只回收了5%的垃圾。今天，台湾回收的垃圾远远超过一半。该国现在名列世界顶级回收国之列。这一时期发生的变化在很大程度上与垃圾收集的方式有关。好吧，《致爱丽丝》并不是卡车播放的唯一歌曲。在台湾首府台北，卡车也播放这首歌曲。那是波兰作曲家泰克拉·巴拉泽夫斯卡·巴拉泽卡（Tekla Bądarzewska-Baranowska）的《少女的祈祷》。在台北市，垃圾车就在这两首歌曲之间交替播放。
The tech turns to play these two songs, two music, the in Taipei City. Even the elementary school kids can sing the song. So we have brainwashed. This is Dr. Jasmine Wan, and she grew up in Taipei. Since I was a child, I knew that every time when the garbage truck comes, we were here, no, no, no, no, no. Now the singing garbage trucks are such a part of life, it's hard to imagine a time before them, but that time actually wasn't too long ago.
卡车轮流播放这两首歌曲，两首音乐，在台北市。连小学生的都会唱这首歌。所以我们已经被洗脑了。这是贾斯敏·万博士（Dr. Jasmine Wan），她在台北长大。从小我就知道，每当垃圾车来的时候，我们都会在这里，不，不，不，不，不。现在，会唱歌的垃圾车已经是生活的一部分，很难想象没有它们的时代，但那个时代其实并不久远。
We used to have a lot of big dumpsters, so they were a lot of rats, mosquitoes, and things like that, and it's not good for our health. Just a couple of decades ago, Taipei residents threw their trash into massive, smelly dumpsters on the streets. Garbage would end up in piles on the sidewalk and in parks. It would fester in the heat. It was just nasty. Then Taiwan's democratization accelerated in the mid-1980s
我们过去有很多大的垃圾箱，所以有很多老鼠、蚊子之类的小动物，这对我们的健康不好。就在几十年前，台北居民把垃圾扔在大街上巨大的、臭气熏天的垃圾箱里。垃圾最终会堆积在人行道上和公园里。它们会在炎热中腐烂。那简直太令人讨厌了。然后台湾的民主化在20世纪80年代中期加速，
and created this desire to tidy up. Being a modern country means being a clean country. And when you have foreign visitors coming and visiting your capital, they shouldn't think, oh, this place is dirty. This is Mary Alice Hadad, chair of East Asian Studies at Wesleyan University. In Taiwan, the pro-democracy movement got fully entangled with the environmental movement.
并产生了整理干净的渴望。成为一个现代化国家意味着成为一个干净的国家。当你接待外国游客参观你的首都时，他们不应该认为，哦，这个地方很脏。这是卫斯理大学东亚研究系主任玛丽·爱尔兰·哈达德（Mary Alice Haddad）。在台湾，民主化运动与环保运动完全交织在了一起。
And so as all those things moved together in the late 80s, early 90s, then the pro-democracy and pro-environment agendas got onto the public consciousness. Also, the environmental movement had a practical end. Taiwan was running out of space to actually put piles of trash because it's a small island, an extremely populous small island. There's not that much space where you're gonna stick
因此，随着所有这些事情在80年代末、90年代初共同推进，亲民主和亲环境的议程进入了公众意识。此外，环保运动也有一个现实的目的。台湾的实际空间快要容纳不下成堆的垃圾了，因为它是一个小岛，一个极其人口稠密的小岛。没有那么多空间可以塞下
all your junk, whereas in the United States, there has been historically a sense of the untamed, untabbed, endless wilderness. And you could just throw your junk into the wilderness and it would go away and you wouldn't have to worry about it anymore. Not true in Taipei. It's a big city, but it's really clean and the subways are clean and the stores are clean and the sidewalks are clean and it's really pleasant to be there.
你所有的垃圾，而在美国，历史上有一种未驯服的、未开发的、无尽荒野的感觉。你可以把你的垃圾扔进荒野，它就会消失，你再也不用担心了。台北可不是这样。这是一座大城市，但它真的很干净，地铁很干净，商店很干净，人行道很干净，呆在那里真的很惬意。
You'd never know that the city used to have piles of garbage littering the streets. Taipei and a number of other Taiwanese cities reduce the amount of trash by changing the way the trash got collected. Take a look at my garbage. This is my friend Aaron Newport. She lives in Taipei where the garbage truck comes five nights a week evenings like after work. It comes Monday Tuesday Thursday Friday and Saturday. In Erin's neighborhood trucks come twice in the evening at 5 and at 7. Normally you take out the trash like once a week on one of the days.
你永远不会知道这座城市过去曾有堆积如山的垃圾散落在街道上。台北和台湾的其他一些城市通过改变垃圾收集的方式减少了垃圾量。看看我的垃圾。这是我的朋友艾伦·纽波特（Erin Newport）。她住在台北，那里的垃圾车一周来五个晚上的傍晚，就像下班后一样。它在周一、周二、周四、周五和周六来。在艾伦的街区，卡车在傍晚5点和7点来两次。通常你一周倒一次垃圾，就在其中一天。
Ah, yeah, usually once. I mean, it's kind of hard sometimes to find the time to always be home at 5 or 7. Erin has to gather her own garbage and recycling and bring it out to a designated street corner and wait for the big yellow truck to come with an ear perked for the sound of furilies or maintenance prayer coming down the block. Basically, this is a binless system or a garbage canless system. Your trash goes right from your house to the truck, ideally without ever touching the street. You just have to bring out your garbage in a special bag.
啊，是的，通常是一次。我的意思是，有时候要在5点或7点准时在家确实有点难。艾伦必须收拾好自己的垃圾和回收物，把它拿到指定的街角，竖起耳朵等待《致爱丽丝》或《少女的祈祷》的声音顺着街区传来，然后等待黄色大卡车到来。基本上，这是一个没有垃圾桶的系统，或者说没有垃圾桶的系统。你的垃圾直接从你的家里送到卡车上，理想情况下绝不触碰街道。你只需要把垃圾装在专门的袋子里拿出来。
I pay my garbage bill by purchasing these blue Taipei City garbage bags. These official blue garbage bags say city of Taipei on them and each is emblazoned with a stamp. I buy them from the convenience store across the street. The official blue garbage bags come in a number of different sizes ranging from three liters to 120 liters, so the more garbage you throw away, the more it'll cost you. And although Taipei residents have to pay for their garbage by the bag, recycling and
我通过购买这些蓝色的台北市垃圾袋来支付垃圾费。这些官方的蓝色垃圾袋上印着“台北市”，每个袋子上都有一个印章。我从街对面的便利店买它们。官方的蓝色垃圾袋有多种不同尺寸，从3升到120升不等，所以你扔的垃圾越多，花费就越多。尽管台北居民必须按袋支付垃圾费，但回收和
compost are free. You don't need to buy bags for them at all. You can just take out your recycling in non-official plastic bags, and you can generate as much compost and recycling as you'd like. So residents are incentivized to recycle more and throw out less. I watched Aaron sort out all of her recyclables into perfect categories. These are the cans, cans and bottles, so we have a few tea bottles. So, when Taipei, every yellow garbage truck is followed by a small, white recycling truck,
堆肥是免费的。你根本不需要为此买袋子。你可以直接用非官方的塑料袋把回收物拿出去，并且你可以产生任意多的堆肥和回收物。因此，居民被激励去回收更多并减少丢弃。我看着艾伦把她所有的回收物分类成完美的类别。这些是罐头，罐子和瓶子，所以我们有一些茶瓶。所以，在台北，每辆黄色垃圾车后面都跟着一辆小白回收车，
which is basically a cart full of different bins. There's a bin for plastic bottles, one for glass bottles, different metals and cans, papers and cardboard, and a compost bucket for raw food waste, and a compost bucket for cooked food waste. Type residents have to sort their recycling into all these different categories themselves. Although in the white recycling trucks there are officials and volunteers who can help instruct you about which item goes where. So Erin, her housemates and I got all of her bags of trash and different kinds of recycling sorted out and then we walked about a block down the street to wait with the rest of her neighbors who were all clutching official blue garbage bags. I've heard a lot of people gather here today and say this is maybe larger than your average
基本上就是一个装满各种分类垃圾桶的手推车。有一个装塑料瓶的，一个装玻璃瓶的，装各种金属和易拉罐的，装纸张和纸板的，还有一个装生厨余垃圾的堆肥桶，以及一个装熟厨余垃圾的堆肥桶。台北居民必须自己把回收物分类到所有这些不同的类别中。不过在白色的回收卡车上有工作人员和志愿者，可以指导你什么东西该扔进哪个桶里。于是，艾琳、她的室友和我把她所有的垃圾袋和各种回收物都分好类，然后我们步行走到街区尽头，和她的其他邻居一起等待，大家手里都紧紧抓着官方的蓝色垃圾袋。我听说今天很多人聚在这里，说这可能比你想象的还要多
crew. And then the moment we were waiting for. There was this mad dash of people swarming to the school bus yellow garbage truck and the white recycling truck. Okay, this one, yeah, people are tossing it in. Swiftly tossing their separate recyclables and the bins, tossing their blue bags and the garbage truck and running away. It was madness, like extremely well organized madness.
人员。接着就是我们一直在等待的时刻。人们疯狂地冲向那辆校车黄色的垃圾车和白色的回收车。好吧，就是这个，没错，大家纷纷把东西扔进去。迅速地把各自的回收物扔进垃圾桶，把蓝色垃圾袋扔进垃圾车然后跑开。这太疯狂了，就像是一场极其井然有序的疯狂景象。
That was so chaotic. In this system, for all its chaos has been working. Taipei City used to produce 3,296 tons of trash a day. Today, the city produces about 1,000 tons a day. That is, according to Chen Wichu, one of 65 officials who supervise the garbage trucks and their routes. I met him at a garbage pickup site where Jasmine Wong acted as interpreter. Every radio is a Mr. Chen. Hi. And he is a supervisor. In his district, Chen oversees 20 garbage truck
刚才那一幕真是太混乱了。这个系统尽管充满了混乱，但确实一直在发挥作用。台北市过去每天产生3296吨垃圾。如今，该市每天产生大约1000吨垃圾。这是根据陈维初的说法，他是监督垃圾车及其路线的65名官员之一。我在一个垃圾收集点遇到了他，黄asmine担任翻译。每一个对讲机里都是陈先生。嗨。他是主管。在他的辖区内，陈监督着20条垃圾车
routes and all those trucks have to make sure that citizens are sorting properly. If they find garbage in the recycling bag, the people here will tell them that you cannot do that one more time, otherwise you would get ticket. And how much is the ticket? 200 US dollars. But that's the maximum. And you might think this is such a drag. There must be some people who buck the system
路线，所有这些卡车都必须确保市民进行了正确的分类。如果他们在回收袋里发现垃圾，这里的人就会告诉他们，这种事不能再做一次，否则你会收到罚单。罚单要多少钱？200美元。但这已经是最高金额了。你可能会觉得这太麻烦了。肯定会有些人通过把垃圾扔进公共垃圾桶来
by tossing their trash into public trash cans. Well, there are hardly any public trash cans in Taipei. They're only in train stations or at bus stops. And those are little that come up just below your knees. So in Taipei, for the most part, if you eat a candy or buy a coffee, you just take your empty coffee cup or your candy wrapper, put it in your pocket and bring it home. It's your trash that you put in your blue bag
逃避这个系统。好吧，台北几乎没有什么公共垃圾桶。它们只存在于火车站或公交车站。而且那些垃圾桶很小，只到你的膝盖下方。所以在台北，大多数情况下，如果你吃了一颗糖或者买了一杯咖啡，你只需要把空咖啡杯或糖纸放进你的口袋，然后带回家。这是你要放进蓝色垃圾袋的垃圾
and bring out to the truck yourself. It's hard to imagine a system like this working here in the US. Every city here has a different method of trash pickup, but across the board, the uniting factor is that our American trash pickup system strive to be invisible. The trucks make great efforts to come when we're working, or sleeping, or trying to sleep, keeping out of the way of traffic and not disturbing the flow of the city. We take our trash and recycling out to bins or down a chute or to a dumpster, and it's gone.
然后自己拿到卡车旁。很难想象这样的系统能在美国行得通。这里的每个城市都有不同的垃圾收集方法，但总的来说，共同点是我们的美国垃圾收集系统力求隐形。卡车竭力在我们工作、睡觉或试图睡觉的时候来，避开交通高峰，不干扰城市的正常运转。我们把垃圾和回收物拿到垃圾桶、垃圾滑道或大垃圾箱里，然后它们就消失了。
We don't have to think about it. According to the EPA, Americans are cycle and compost about 34% of their trash, which is less than most rich countries. But some American cities do a lot better. San Francisco has probably the most forward recycling program in North America. This is Robert Reed. He's the representative of Recology, the company that takes care of San Francisco's waste
我们完全不用去想它。根据美国环保署的数据，美国人回收和堆肥大约34%的垃圾，这比大多数富裕国家都要少。但一些美国城市做得好得多。旧金山可能拥有北美最超前的回收计划。这位是罗伯特·里德。他是Recology公司的代表，该公司负责处理旧金山的废弃物
recycling and compost. Unlike Taipei, which has a public trash pickup system, many waste pickup services in the U.S. are private companies, and we are the customers. That's how it works with ecology, which means they've got to keep their customers happy. Our number one focus is to provide superior customer service. And our next focus is to do as much recycling as possible
回收和堆肥。与拥有公共垃圾收集系统的台北不同，美国的许多垃圾收集服务都是私营公司，而我们是客户。Recology就是这样运作的，这意味着他们必须让客户满意。我们的首要任务是提供卓越的客户服务。我们的下一个任务是尽可能多地进行回收
and to make recycling easy and convenient for customers. Rekology has set up similar incentives to the system in Taipei, where trash pick-up is way more expensive than recycling or compost pick-up. For example, in San Francisco, recycling and compost cost about $2 a month per bin. Trash is about $26 a month per bin. But above all, Recology's system is meant to be simple and stress-free. It has to be if you want people to keep paying for your service.
并使客户回收变得简单方便。Recology设立了类似于台北系统的激励机制，即垃圾收集的费用比回收或堆肥收集昂贵得多。例如，在旧金山，回收和堆肥每个垃圾桶每月大约花费2美元。垃圾则是每个垃圾桶每月约26美元。但最重要的是，Recology的系统旨在简单且无压力。如果你想让人们继续为你付费的服务，它必须如此。
People have a lot of demands in their lives, we understand that. You know, recycling might not be the very first thing. They've got to make their boss happy, they've got to pay their mortgage. Garbage recycling and composting might not always be at the top of the list. We understand that. Basically, instead of putting the onus on the citizens to separate the different kinds
人们的生活中有太多的诉求，我们理解这一点。你知道，回收可能不是他们最优先考虑的事情。他们必须让老板满意，他们必须支付房贷。垃圾回收和堆肥可能并不总是排在清单的最前面。我们理解这一点。基本上，Recology没有把要求公民自行分离不同种类的
of compost and recycling for themselves, Recology does the brunt of the work, sorting, so we don't have to. San Francisco, like a lot of other American cities that collect recycling, uses one catch all recycling bin. So you throw your cans, your bottles, your cardboard, all in the same place. And then all those different materials end up in a facility like Recycle Central. So this is Recycle Central.
堆肥和回收的重担压在他们身上，而是承担了大部分的分拣工作，所以我们不必亲自动手。旧金山和许多其他收集回收物的美国城市一样，使用的是一个包罗万象的回收箱。所以你可以把易拉罐、瓶子、纸板都扔在同一个地方。然后所有这些不同的材料最终都会到达像中央回收中心这样的设施。所以这就是中央回收中心。
This is the large recycling plant on Pier 96, where we sort all the materials from the blue bin, the bottles, the cans, the paper. We're gonna go inside now. The facility is massive, and it's where ecology processes most of San Francisco's recycling. You can see this great big pile of recycling. This is from this morning. This is from one day, and we're going to get this sorted out because we've got another
这是位于96号码头的大型回收厂，我们在这里对来自蓝色垃圾桶的所有材料进行分类，包括瓶子、易拉罐和纸张。我们现在要进里面去了。这个设施非常庞大，是Recology处理旧金山大部分回收物的地方。你可以看到一大堆回收物。这是今天早上的。这是一天的量，我们要把这些分拣出来，因为我们还有另一个
big pile coming in tomorrow. So we do 600 tons a day here. That 600 ton pile will wind its way up a huge surreal web of conveyor belts, where some of the 173 people on staff will separate the recyclables into 16 categories of materials, with the help of some modern recycling equipment. materials, with the help of some modern recycling equipment. So we've got magnets and we have fish ladders that separate bottles and cans from paper. They're on an angle and they temporarily suspend gravity. And to make sure everything gets precisely sorted, there's some real state-of-the-art technology,
明天要运进来的巨大堆积物。所以我们这里每天处理600吨。这600吨的堆积物将蜿蜒穿过一个巨大的、超现实的传送带网络，在一些现代回收设备的协助下，173名员工中的一部分人会将可回收物分成16大类材料。材料，在一些现代回收设备的协助下。所以我们有磁铁，还有能把瓶子和罐头从纸张中分离出来的鱼梯。它们呈一定角度倾斜，并暂时中止重力。为了确保每样东西都能被精确分类，这里有一些最先进的技术，
like this apparatus that separates clear plastic from color plastic with optic sensors. Right here, the scanner is looking at the materials as they come by and when it sees a clear plastic, like a clear plastic water bottle, it hits it with a puff of air. And you can hear it. It's expensive. It costs $3 million for this machine, and it came from the Netherlands. So this system, with all its worrying, twirling conveyors and magnets and machinery and 173 employees,
比如这个利用光学传感器将透明塑料与彩色塑料分离的装置。就在这里，扫描仪在材料通过时对其进行观察，当它看到透明塑料（如透明塑料水瓶）时，就会用一股气流将其吹开。你能听到声音。这很贵。这台机器价值300万美元，来自荷兰。因此，这个系统拥有所有令人眼花缭乱、旋转的传送带、磁铁、机械装置以及173名员工，
it's dazzling. It makes less trash by doing more recycling. And recycling creates 10 times more jobs than landfilling or incineration. Of course, it also takes all the direct sorting out of the hands of the people who actually create the waste and charges them for the service instead. As a result, recycling in the US can be expensive. I guess that's part of the problem, like to the extent that there's pushback in recycling,
它令人眼花缭乱。它通过做更多的回收来产生更少的垃圾。而且回收利用创造的就业机会是垃圾填埋或焚烧的10倍。当然，这也把直接分拣的工作从真正产生垃圾的人手中拿走，转而向他们收取服务费。因此，在美国回收利用可能很昂贵。我想这就是问题的一部分，比如在某种程度上，对回收利用的抵制，
which I've seen some of in the United States now, it's often about the cost of it, and now it's very costly. of it in the United States now is often about the cost of it and that's true if you're using these single-stream processes function and it's less true if the household does the separating. That's Professor Mary Alice Hadad again. If your community wants to recycle, all that stuff needs to be separated and sorted, somehow. Whether you use a $3 million machine from the Netherlands or compel an entire sweet potato-shaped island of people to stand on the corner at night. The Taipei system is cheap and efficient because the city has conscripted their citizens as workers, and it's been successful. Taipei is a great example
我在美国现在已经看到了一些，这往往是关于它的成本问题，而且现在成本非常高。在美国，这往往是关于成本的问题，如果你使用这些单流处理功能确实如此，而如果由家庭自己分类，这种情况就会少一些。这就是玛丽·爱丽丝·哈达德教授的又一次发言。如果你的社区想要回收利用，所有这些东西都需要以某种方式被分离和分类。无论你是使用来自荷兰的300万美元机器，还是强迫一个长得像红薯的岛屿上的人们晚上站在街角。台北的系统既便宜又高效，因为该市将市民征召为工人，而且它非常成功。
of a big major global metropolitan area that did not have a good garbage collection system not that long ago and they have completely transformed and it could be an example for us all. Which is not to say we should necessarily copy Taipei's system. What's worked for them might not work for the US. But consider the American garbage truck, creeping around at dawn or during work hours, trying to be as inconspicuous as possible, trying to keep trash out of sight and out of mind. You don't really pay attention to it, but everyone should pay a lot of attention. If we had to watch our garbage pile up in our homes without taking it out to the bin
台北是一个很好的例子，展示了一个大型全球大都市地区在不久前还没有一个良好的垃圾收集系统，但他们已经彻底改变了，这可以成为我们所有人的榜样。这并不是说我们应该盲目照搬台北的系统。对他们有效的方法可能不适用于美国。但想想美国的垃圾车，在黎明或工作时间蹑手蹑脚地行驶，尽量不引人注目，尽量让垃圾视线之外，脑海之外。你并不真正关注它，但每个人都应该高度关注。如果我们不得不看着垃圾在家里堆积而不把它拿出去扔进垃圾桶
and had to set aside time in our days to catch the garbage and recycling trucks coming down the street, I bet we'd produce less junk. But I also think if I had to hear this song twice a night five days a week, I would murder everybody. everybody. If you like that story, there are like 300 more episodes just like it in the archives. Even if you read the description of the title and you think, well, I'm not really into
并且必须在日常生活中留出时间来迎接街上开来的垃圾和回收垃圾车，我敢打赌我们会产生更少的垃圾。但我也认为，如果我一周五天、一天听两次这首歌，我会把所有人都杀掉。如果你喜欢这个故事，档案里还有大约300个类似的剧集。即使你阅读了标题的描述，你觉得，嗯，我其实并不喜欢
that. Download it and listen to it anyway, because this show is about making everyday things interesting, so take the leap and go for it. 99% of visible was produced this week by Avery Trouffleman, mix in tech production by Sheree Fusef, music by Sean Rihau. Katie Mingle is the senior producer Kurt Colstade is the digital director. The rest of the team is senior editor Delaney Hall, and it fits Gerald, Taren Mazza, Joe Rosenberg, Vivian Lee, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks to Zoe Heller, the policy director of Cal recycle, Noah Omen and Randy Hartman, keep America beautiful, Lee Uwa, Greenpeace, and to Hillary Prattgo, for sounding the alarm about the problem we talked about in the first
下载并收听它，因为这个节目旨在让日常事物变得有趣，所以勇敢尝试并去做吧。本周的“99%的可视化”由Avery Trouffleman制作，混音和技术制作由Sheree Fusef完成，音乐由Sean Rihau创作。Katie Mingle是高级制作人，Kurt Colstade是数字总监。团队其余成员包括高级编辑Delaney Hall，以及It Fits Gerald、Taren Mazza、Joe Rosenberg、Vivian Lee、Sophia Klatsker和我Roman Mars。特别感谢加州回收局政策总监Zoe Heller、Noah Omen和Randy Hartman、Keep America Beautiful、绿色和平组织的Lee Uwa，以及Hillary Prattgo，感谢她通过向我们发送她的杂志《垃圾地图》为我们谈论的第一部分中的问题敲响了警钟
part of this episode by sending us herzine atlasoforngarpage, we'll have a link on the website. We are a project of 91.7KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. 99% of visible is a member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. Find them all at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI at work, or on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too.
本集的一部分将在网站上提供链接。我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，制作于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽市中心电台街的广播室。99% Visible 是 PRX 旗下 Radiotopia 的成员，Radiotopia 是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的激烈独立的集体。请访问 radiotopia.fm 查找所有这些内容。您可以在 Facebook 上找到该节目并参与有关该程序的讨论。你可以在 Twitter 上@我 Roman Mars，也可以在工作时@99PI，或者在 Instagram、Tumblr 和 Reddit 上。
But if you're in that great episode from 2016, made you think, I really gotta go back and listen to more of the older shows. Well, that's good thinking. And we got you cover. All the episodes are at 99PI.org. Radio til the end. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但如果你看了2016年的那一集精彩剧集，让你觉得，我真的得回去听更多旧节目了。嗯，那是个好主意。我们已经为你准备好了。所有剧集都在 99PI.org 上。电台直到永远。来自 PRX。本集尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。